in raleigh north carolina jordan what's
up hey i married my wife
about a year ago she is a full-time
paramedic
and is in pa school over the past
few months she's been taking
unprescribed xanax
on and off where's she getting it makes
this
the first time um i
had some uh i get like crazy anxiety
from flying
so i have taken xanax three times in my
life
for the past three flights i've been on
um
i had a couple in a sock drawer
basically
that was the first time she took them um
and then the times after that she's been
uh she found a drug dealer and has been
going to him
okay um so well makes it a little bit
what's that go ahead man i'll get on you
later we'll go ahead i want to keep it
right good you're good
yeah you're good what makes this a
little more scary is that she struggled
with heroin addiction in the past
um so i guess my question is how do i
continue to love and support her
at the same time not start to build up
resentment
and our boundaries an option so the
first thing is to stop giving your
former heroin addict wife drugs
that's number one oh yeah yeah i did
i did not give them to her whatsoever
did she steal them from you yeah she
took them from me she did
uh they were not given to her i would
never in a million years do that ever
i'm sorry if that's what it sounded like
so i did not give them to her
so when when did she
how did that conversation go when you
found out she had stolen your your
prescription medication
so i didn't know uh because i don't i
i pull them out when i go on flights and
i don't fly very often
so i never would have known honestly i
don't plan on going anywhere
anytime soon so she told me the very
next day she took them there were
there were three in there and she took
all three
we woke up the next morning and first
thing in the morning she said hey
there's something i got to tell you
you're you're xanax
i took them and i i took them all and
you know
she apologized and everything okay
so that was the first yeah so is she now
getting
these prescribed to her by doctor no
no she's um she's finding them
uh you know she's calling uh a drug
dealer and meeting
okay meeting with them to to get them
yeah so
i'm just gonna be i have a a psychiatric
um i have a part of my will which is a
psychiatric power of attorney
meaning if i ever disassociate and i
have to be institutionalized
what do i want them to do to me while
i'm there
what do i not want them to do while i'm
there
and the addictive properties of xanax
and other benzos benzodiazepines it is
so bad
i have in my psychiatric
power of attorney that if i'm
institutionalized
they are not allowed to give me that
drug wow
that's how much i hate that drug
yeah and it should never be given as a
one-off
right as a tic-tac as a as a feel-good
right
yeah and so i got a problem with
whatever doctor gave them to you that
way right
and right right the second is yeah if
you've got an active addict in the home
having prescription medications is man
that's not wise
the second the second thing is
she is a paramedic dude she other
people's
lives count on her being fully present
and not
high and so this is a marriage issue
obviously one year in this is an
addiction issue one year in
and this is an also a professional
ethics issue she's gonna kill somebody
man
yeah you know what i mean right now she
i do know for a fact she's not taking
these on
the job um hey listen listen brother
listen
yeah i know but you know too right
right yeah yeah no i am i don't want to
be in the business of
running your wife down okay i'm trying
to get you to realize how serious this
is
okay right and i know you know that it's
serious but um
so at the end of the day if your wife
has a heroin addiction in her past
and she is back to i'm as concerned
about the the actual narcotic as i am
about the behavior the sneaking
the off script the um
lying the then circling back and i'm
sorry it won't happen again
and then i'm going to a dealer now all
the while i'm
in a really really high stress
emotionally high strung job and by the
way i'm going to go ahead and get a
graduate degree too on top of that
um that's probably why you called but
brother that is a
recipe for a train wreck right right
right yeah so when you sit down and have
this hard conversation with her
how does it go what does she say um
well this is we didn't have the hard
conversation
up until a couple days ago because after
this has happened on and off for about
three months
and in between those three months it's
only happened about
um where she has come to me to tell him
to tell me that she's
you know taken a xanax um
it's only happened just a handful of
times so i do
i guarantee you you take that number
and double it right yeah if not you're
right
but but the way we handle it from there
is thank you you know first of all thank
you for telling me
you know i know you're going through a
lot like what
you know what what's kind of leading to
this you know where are you at
mentally you know or emotionally when
you take one and you know
can we find ways to fill that hole
another way you know she likes to
you know she likes fitness and she likes
to journal and read you know so
just trying to find you know ways
to cope other than you know xanax
because i know
her job is ridiculous right right um
so this last time we we had a fight and
it kind of was me
getting to a point of like okay i've
said sorry
i've gotten over it and pressed on
and now i'm in a selfish way i guess
now i want some answers you know yeah
i think i think that's fair i think
that's super fair yeah
um and it yeah the con basically the
conversation was
you know let's uh um
basically what you know show me what
you're doing tell me what you're doing
you know to fill to fill this whole
let's you know come up with a i guess it
doesn't sound any different
than it's always been but um right
exactly yeah and hey here's what's going
on
i called you yeah yeah no i and and man
i'm grateful for you and i know that you
are
trying to love your wife the best way
you know how okay so i'm not i'm not
drinking a headache on that one at all i
know you're trying to love her the best
you can
um what's going to end up happening is
that
that constricting pressure those old
demons that are being
that are coming out that surfaced with
whatever trauma led to the heroin
addiction right and the things that
happened before that and i bet you and i
could talk for a long time about her
her heroine history right and her
pre-hearing history right
is that am i fair am i right on that
absolutely
okay so she she comes here whatever
stressors are going on her life
and those demons start calling the
tendency
that you're gonna have is compassion
first
like right just like hey what's going on
how can we help hey there's just some
other things we can do and
really quick you are going to get lumped
into
the box of stressors you are going to
become part of the problem because
you're going to be something
that she has to work around because you
are holding her accountable
you want to see these behaviors you want
to see these things change the same as
the paramedic job the same as the grad
school homework
and a partridge in a pear tree and
pretty soon she's already practicing
deceiving you
right and pretty soon that's just if
it's not already
that's just going to be common that's
just going to be a a routine in your
home
and so i i don't want to
sound any alarms unnecessarily but this
is this relationship's on real shaky
shaky ground
and i'm worried about the health and
heart of your wife okay
is she working with a professional at
all with a counselor how did she how did
she kick her heroin habit
uh rehab and then
she she did some in a uh
she's done that a couple times uh she's
been in rehab a couple times in the past
and um she kicked heroin before we met
uh with sober for a long time then
left the program and just
would do a glass of wine every
you know every other day or something
maybe it kind of empowered her in a way
that
she was like you know wow i used to not
be able to even finish up
like i used to i've been healed right
yeah i'm all good now yeah
okay right um and then this just kind of
led to
where we are now so but to answer your
question uh she does have a therapist
um she meets um over zoom
maybe once a month so here's
here's your next move uh and and i'm
i'm telling you this this is what i
would do if i was in the same situation
with the woman i love the woman that i
really want to be well and i i see her
on a
path to um destruction right
i would tell her that i and i would do
this while i'm holding her hands
right so she feels you um i would let
her know that you are
real you're terrified that's the best
word i can tell you that you're
terrified and you're scared for her and
about her and she's gonna try to make
you feel better she's gonna go into
paramedic mode she's good at that that's
what she does
she goes into people's hardest moments
and brings the the noise level down and
helps them there
and then i want you to ask her for
permission to
join her in her next session her next
counseling session
because you are worried about the xanax
and the sneaky behavior and the hiding
behavior
and here's what you can do in a
beautiful vulnerable way that is also
truthful and honoring to her
you can tell her that you are struggling
with hearing her um
hearing her stories is true that you are
having frustr
you are having concerns and doubts and
fears so you're not going to call her a
liar
but you're going to let her know hey i'm
starting to struggle with these doubts
and i don't want
we're a year in i don't want our
relationship to get any more cracks in
the foundation than it needs to
i want to join you with your counselor i
want to let your counselor know what's
going on i want us to be on the same
page together
i'm not helping you by giving you a
bunch of new rules
and a bunch of new behaviors that you've
got to start showing me
i'm not helping but i don't have the
tools to to do this on my own
i want to join you and that's when you
are going to ask um
if she lets you do this then you're
going to talk openly and candidly with
the counselor and the counselor is going
to give you some
very real and direct strategies and
tools and if the counselor doesn't
and says something dumb like well what
do you think then i want you to find
another counselor or find a marriage
counselor on zoom
and then you both are going to go do
that you're going to be vulnerable here
on two different counts
number one you're going to ask her for
something that you need and she might
tell you no
and if she says you cannot join my
counseling session i refuse
then every alarm bell you have should go
off about the status and safety of your
relationship
and the second thing is this man she's
been through the ringer before
and she understands the trajectory she's
on
cognitively it's just that that
spiritual part that addiction demon man
is mean mean mean
right gnarly and hopefully your
counselor
y'all's counselor her counselor will
walk you through a series of really hard
boundaries that you're gonna hold hard
hard hard and is gonna give you some
tools on how to hold your wife with a
lot a lot a lot of grace
okay so i don't want to again be an
alarmist
your situation is real rough right now
brother
and your wife situation is rough and
scary
and um she's headed not in a good
direction
and again if you're listing this and
you're like dude she took three xanax
chill out she got like 10 xanax from
some dude at work what is your problem
when you have a history of addiction
when you are in a helping profession on
top of a graduate school um
a challenging graduate school program at
that
man those demons come calling and it
starts with one and it starts with two
and three and then it starts with the
i'm just gonna steal these from my
husband and i'll tell them about it
later and see how i'm gonna test the
water there oh he was kind of cool
he forgave me cool i'm gonna have
another one i'm gonna tell him about
this one but i'm
only gonna talk about every fifth one
and now we're setting up new
rhythms to our day we are lying as a
regular part of life
and the stress never gets dealt with the
pain never gets dealt with the
connection starts to fracture and
fissure with the dishonesty and suddenly
man you are full blown over your head
again
the only way through addiction is
through connection with other people
and that's what makes addiction so evil
is there's so many barriers to keep you
from having to connect and it just loops
on itself
and so hey jordan i want you to have
that hard conversation with her i want
you to ask
if you can join her and speak openly
with her counselor on her behalf
on your behalf and then i want you to
call me back and let me know how that
goes
and i'm happy to receive a call from her
if she wants to call me
she says i'm full of crap tell her give
me a shout or if she's getting scared
tell her to give me a shout and if you
want to call me back i'd love to talk to
you too thank you for that call
um these are hard hard times man
if you've got somebody in your life that
has struggled with addiction in the past
man be smart and open and
intelligent and those are all three
different things be smart and
intelligent about having prescription
medication in the house
be really weary of benzos man talk hard
with your doctor and your psychiatrist
there was a season where they were just
passing those suckers out like tic tacs
and they've rained them in the last
couple of years just because they're so
stinking addictive
but they are they're just passed out
like bubble gums in in
in certain pockets still i stay away
from those with
every ounce of my being and um those are
tough tough tough
man brother jordan my heart's out for
you man